you received a terrorist threat terrace  from live from everywhere mr. secretary  is there any hope for a breakthrough in  the Russia crisis I have very little  confidence in a resolution here in  Moscow you guys enjoy your life all  right for the power you have left of it  this should get her grandfather's  attention  why are these guys  someone wanted to trace Russia's economy  a great way to do with his instead of  the crisis  we have to fix this ourselves  are you really here the less you know  the shorter your prison sentence will be  I'm scared  my stakes game here I intend to win  you don't look handled to me Tony  [Music]  Fred  [Music]  you  you